you are about to witness a prophecy of
Islam come true right before your eyes
so we've been driving for about six
hours we caught a flight in the morning
for an hour of a humble of it finally
here where the village of the Kimber
people they are an indigenous people who
seclude themselves from the outside
world Valley Fire is a place where the
core and motion to the ancestors when
they're sick when it rains when it's all
the other blessing they do go there the
men only covered the lower parts of
their body and the women didn't cover
their bodies either a stuff for Allah of
the rahim
how dare you guys give Islam to naked
people let me remind you at the time of
the Prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam
people used to do tow off around the
Kaaba completely naked did The Messenger
of Allah stop or did he continue giving
dower these people deserve to learn
about Allah and we believe God is only
one God we all come from different
places in the world our faith Islam
unites us all we shared the beautiful
and simple message of Islam our belief
in one God the Creator and how simple it
was the tribes chief he told them if you
believe and understand what our guests
are saying and find it to be the truth
and feel free to accept it Allahu Akbar
the chief had done the job for us they
got up and testified to what we had
explained to them
Oh
the Himba tribe live in coal shaped
homes made from mud trees and cattle
dung the village was literally as the
prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam
described this matter of Islam will
reach where the night and day have
reached and it will not leave a house of
mud or a house of fur
except Allah will bring it into this
deal the guys if you can see this mud on
our head is because we just did our
salah in front of them and spanner for
some of these people it was the first to
do that they did to this tribe in the
middle of nowhere
look how love what islam to them guided
them to the straight path and now they
made their first touch as well this is
your opportunity to be part of the
reward what are you waiting for if you
miss out now and don't give during the
Ramadan you won't get the ten to seven
hundred times or even more reward click
the button and donate now and please
please please don't forget to share this
video it's free and you would also share
in the reward of others donating for
free
[Music]